just a brief tangent on that I thought
redgar was a really really good game I
played it as a
and again again you don't you know just
you you forget stuff but I remember
getting um
I guess it was the first in the Elder
Scrolls series to put it in into that
world but it was like an adventure game
it reminded me of another game I really
love like Prince of Persia that was the
and one of The Inspirations one of my
favorite games like
I apologize if I'm forgetting but you
can like jump in buildings and stuff
like there's a jumping there's a dynamic
like Airy nature like it's like yeah
that was a situation
um yeah it was an incredible game why do
you think let me ask sort of a dark
question why do you think that game was
a flop one of the one of the few not a
dark question yeah it was
um well a lot of reasons
um game game that I love and really got
us going on a handcrafted world so we're
coming off a Daggerfall Morrowind is
sort of in design
and then you know part of our
development teams broke up to do
different things this game would did
battle spire and Red Guard was my game
um
and I wanted to do something a little
more Ultima feeling handcrafted world I
really like things that blend up genres
so I know it's in the adventure game
category but it really does a lot of
things you know it's it's a it's a love
letter to Prince of Persia there's a
little Raiders of the Lost Ark in it
there's a lot of Ultima in it
um and really see what we could do with
the engine
but it's very much I think plays like it
would have had a much better home on say
Playstation or Xbox this is predates
Xbox
right where it's a much more like
constantly Tomb Raider had come out so
do you see those influences of Tomb
Raider on that game and
3D effects cards had just come out and
so okay we can do and it was the last I
think it's one of the last like dos
games in a Windows world so it I think
it missed kind of a technology window as
well as
ultimately not what people wanted from
us
you know
um
and
I felt
I was really kind of the company let me
make that game and it it was a big flop
battle Spire hadn't done well the
company was in really bad shape and I
felt really like personally responsible
like they let me do this creative thing
it didn't do what we needed it to do and
now we're in a very very bad situation a
company almost went out of business
and that's when it got reformed with
xenomax media and Robert Altman came in
and we were starting more when we had
just sort of started and it was sort of
that whole experience that made you sort
of realize someone says okay you're
gonna get another shot
and that's where like okay we're gonna
make Morrowind
and make the biggest best RPG we can
make we know what the audience wants
from us we know what we could do
building a world so there's like
callbacks to how we built the world in
Red Guard Morrowind is a large-scale
handcrafted but if you were to put it
you know pixel per pixel with Daggerfall
you wouldn't even see Morrowind like
because Daggerfall is so big but the
impact of playing it I think is in many
ways equal but different
just you personally psychologically did
you have doubt about yourself from from
the performance of Red Guard like do I
even do I know what it is of course of
course where do you get the how do you
overcome that
I
don't know I would say this honestly I
enjoy it so much you know like I'm so
I'm so heads down like that becomes For
Better or Worse like my life yeah
um and
it's just something that I want to play
so much it becomes like there's a little
bit you get a little obsessed with it no
but I mean you love Red Guard right so
like doesn't that mean isn't there a
kind of self-doubt about do I know what
it takes to create a great game well no
I think red guard's a great game right
so you were sure even if you're gonna
debate like do I like that game it's
about finding an odd Okay so
I love Red Guard yeah and the people who
play it it won a bunch of awards and it
you know it like critically was a pretty
good game did not sell
and the reason for that again like we
probably made this the wrong type of
game and we missed a technology window
we also thought it was very conservative
we're gonna do this
so my main takeaway was I'm not going to
be conservative again I'm going to swing
for the fences and we've had you know
there'll be some rough edges in swinging
for the fences and shooting for the moon
but we'd rather do that in the land
where we land than be very very
conservative
and what we're putting out there